[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night hey you're wearing a hat
yeah I got a hat on today
I'll wear it for a second
I'll wear it for a second I just I kind
of feel bored Zach says well I got fired
oh no like already what do you fired for
how did that happen
was it because you got sick and you
should have pulled that dick out on him
well
walked up to the boss pulled the dick
out on him and he's like what I got
fired got fired for that says yeah
yeah you
assuming my orientation you [ __ ] you
you're fired that's what happened I'm
sorry exactly now what happened Zach
yeah that sucks
uh Danny Rowling asked for uh asked for
this button right here so I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it real quick
yeah there it goes yeah he also says
that we need a man said I could but and
I was like well [ __ ] man I should have
thought of that I could probably make
that I wrote it down so I remember
because otherwise I will not remember
that actually comes out and says man
said I could didn't we try to find that
one time he says he said that he doesn't
actually say that I don't think
he says man said I don't have to listen
to you
yeah
um I know he says that he says one other
thing that's like a variation I think
the mom said and then he told me because
man said I could I think I think if the
mom quoted him maybe I don't think he
ever says that he just says man says I
don't have to listen to you
yeah I remember him saying man said I
don't have to listen to you yeah yeah I
remember him saying that but and I
remember that he said something else too
like along those same lines that was
shorter but I don't think it was exactly
word for word man said I could yeah but
it was the same Spirit the same
sentiment Zach says no it was that 96
production rate Scientology type
[ __ ] yeah he was telling me about
that uh with the picture I apparently
wasn't meeting the goal of so needless
to say I'm angry and disappointed now
I'm kind of curious as to whether that
place was owned by scientologists
because that sounds like some [ __ ] they
would pull yeah it's like you have to
have you can't make mistakes ever and
like yeah we you did not exhibit endless
[ __ ] boundless growth so therefore
yeah that was like what yeah yeah that
was what really got me like when I
worked there they just they apparently I
was like so you guys apparently believe
that you can just like keep increasing
endless growth like infinitely yeah
because I'm like that's not how things
work it's science time when they were
trying to take over the world right yeah
good luck with that yeah
Danny Rowling said doesn't he say man
said I could when he pisses in the
closet he does he see maybe yeah go back
and look now I'm gonna have to like
rewind because I think we tried to find
that
where he comes out and actually says
that
and I think we've failed to find it
I tell you what if that was my kid and
he pulled that crap where he where he
put the kitty like underneath the couch
cushion and then sat on it I would drop
kick then punt that little [ __ ] kid
right in front of a bus well we weren't
there we don't really know what happened
why'd you try to hurt the kitty I'd have
been like oh don't do that to the kid
God damn it what's up Oak because I like
kitties a lot better than I like
children that's for sure you know what
it is oh you're gonna turn the fan on
let's see how upset she gets about it I
don't know the fan didn't used to bother
her the fan didn't used to bother her
and like now now she sees it she's like
weirded out by it and the thing about it
too is that after after the show like a
lot of times I'll go over there and turn
the fan off and then she still sits
there underneath and like stares at it
like she's waiting for it to come back
she's doing something she's looking at
it she's like weirded out I don't know
what it is didn't used to bother her I
don't know why like why she yells about
it so much now it's [ __ ] crazy oh my
God yeah yeah Zach said basically it was
a number of items scanned per hour and a
minimum required for each hour about 380
something but when you're dealing with a
real large order that takes a couple
hours to complete yeah see I hate that
kind of [ __ ] I hate that kind of like
it's just too stressful you know what I
mean she's looking at it she's like
another fan yeah let me see yeah what's
the Fanboy now she's like why are you
guys looking at me what's the matter
well it's uh Friday and
we decided we're gonna stay in tonight
I mean we don't have to if you really
want to go out but I don't you know I
wasn't really ready yeah well we could
only go to mannequins anyway yeah
and I don't really have that much money
I mean and the thing about it is Memento
Mori is next Friday okay um and we
missed the last one because they did a
Halloween one or we couldn't go to that
because we went to mannequins all right
this was a stand I mean you know but
like I said it's up to you you sound
kind of like bummed out about it
he's not kind of bummed out sick of
being in the house but uh you might be
right
well I don't know I mean like I said we
can but don't you can't like after the
show's over there you can't be like
rushing me like out the door because I'm
gonna have to start over right it's
early anyway you know what I mean it's
early we'll we'll we'll think about it
I'll think about it when when time comes
Richard Brown said cats over kids every
time yeah right I mean seriously
damn kids
[Laughter]
uh DJ manic said I'm staying in tonight
schedule's off because I've been on
vacation all week plus the move so I'm
going out tomorrow night yeah I mean
honestly it's it's kind of better like I
kind of prefer to go out on Saturday
nights just because
um you know I have more time well I want
to get ready I like Fridays over there
at mannequins but yeah that existed it
last time because we couldn't even dance
it was so [ __ ] that's true because I
felt like I didn't even really get to go
out
it was yeah I mean it was fun because we
got to see all the costumes and we got
to talk to people and stuff like that
but yeah it was so crowded in there
that's like you couldn't even answer the
night I was like more like a job yeah we
were just kind of like we stood out on
the back on the Belt yeah not the
balcony the patio patio like pretty much
all night because it wasn't quite as
crowded out there but yeah you could
barely even get in the inside holy crap
and you know that's the thing and I mean
really I couldn't have danced anyway
because I was like paranoid that like
[ __ ] was gonna fall off my costume like
all my sticks were gonna fall out my
hair and all that kind of stuff like I
had comfortable shoes on it wasn't that
but I just kind of felt like my
headpiece was gonna fall off if we go
we'll just go uncomfortable goth We're
not gonna do the [ __ ]
all [ __ ] full dress you know what I
mean yeah just something we put on in a
[ __ ] half hour well you know I can't
really do that though because usually I
have to have like corset and [ __ ] yeah I
understand that I mean yeah well because
it doesn't look good otherwise I don't
really have anything that you can just
like throw on you know what I mean uh
you used to
well that was a long time ago though and
I can't really you know I can't really
afford to like buy a new [ __ ] all the
time
um Zach said I'm going to the gay bar
tonight and getting very very drunk
well you know aim high well because he
got fired yeah I don't blame you I don't
blame you Ian England said my broke ass
is staying in tonight too and then DJ
Maniac said club night is an unpaying
job for some of us at times Tom yeah it
is well it's like that's the thing it's
like I like to go out I'm not saying
that in fact well I mean we used to go
out like pretty much every night I don't
know I don't even remember how we
afforded that but yeah how did we
um now was you could just wear that no
it's too plain I don't really want to
like like I said if I'm only gonna do if
if I'm going I want it dressed up all
right well yeah I mean that's the thing
all right I can't just go looking all
like Dowdy
you know what I'm saying
DJ Maniac said I only do full dress for
the big events I try and stick to
graphic tees and appropriate bottoms and
boots I guess but the thing is it's like
it's easier for guys though because guys
can just like put on like a kind of a
cool pair of pants and some boots and a
black T-shirt and you look cool like
because you know dudes don't usually
like wear like big huge hair or like
elaborate makeup or anything like that
so it's easier for them to just like go
out looking kinda
you know not have to do like a lot of
effort but
Ben says Tom would make a good Herman
Munster oh
no you might
that dude's [ __ ] huge yeah but you
could get
[Laughter]
my grandpa monster
that would be funny too to be honest
with you
well let's see
DJ Maniac said I own an all-white suit
with blood spatter print all over it and
matching platform shoes with goldfish in
them
you if that's if you're not joking then
please send a picture of that outfit I
really got to see that
I really gotta see that
Danny Rowling said uh I really want to
see Tom in all white goth clothes he
used to have
um yeah you don't have any white pants
but you did have like a white like a
long uh jacket
that was pretty cool I don't think I had
two two or three white outfits I don't
think it fits you anymore I had a I had
that white
kind of like a doctor's bondage [ __ ]
doctor Smock thing remember that
remember had that yeah that's right then
I had to [ __ ] white shirt with a
white long vest coat
never unaware of [ __ ] black pants I
didn't have white boots though just with
black bottoms I had that then I had
that long white
frock coat yeah I had that too and I had
some white outfits yeah
I don't have I don't have a lot of
weight I bought a white dress like kind
of a white gothy like Renaissance
looking dress when I was doing
um
Bride of Frankenstein last year the year
before but I don't wear it all that much
because I don't know I just I don't like
I don't think white looks good on me to
be honest
you know I don't know I don't know what
it is but just any time that I've had
the idea to wear something white it's
just like never I don't know I just feel
like it doesn't look good I feel like it
doesn't look good
um Zach says what's a good outfit one
could throw together if they don't have
any goth type clothes like if what do
you mean if you're just like going out
or something yeah
I mean the thing about it throw together
a goth outfit not really your ass but I
mean if you're gonna go to the goth bar
at least like put some black jeans on
and like well if you're a dude like I
said it's if you're a dog it's easier if
you're a dude it's easier don't even
bother
nobody
an entire goth outfit is built around
boots and Footwear
you can have a [ __ ] cool goth shirt
or something right but if you're wearing
slacks and [ __ ] up dress shoes and
Crocs [ __ ] Crocs
but if you have a [ __ ] badass pair of
like uh new rocks they come up to your
[ __ ] knee almost
or even demonia you can wear that with
anything and that ends up being a goth
outfit yeah I really do feel it I feel
like shoes are key yeah it's Footwear
because you could get it with like even
as a girl you could get away with
wearing some kind of more plain stuff
just like a regular black fishnet dress
or something like that if you had like
these really elaborate boots it would
look like super put together I'm giving
away [ __ ] secrets man these
[ __ ] y'all are gonna have to
pay me for this [ __ ]
don't even bother try to look off unless
you have [ __ ] the right Footwear and
it's the standard is boots
got boots and it has to be
the right kind of [ __ ] boot but it's
real popular in your area although it's
usually tends to be like the entry level
would be like a demonius
that's the entry yeah and those aren't
that expensive 120. yeah but I mean
that's not bad for like a pair of like
you know knee-high boots with buckles
and skulls and [ __ ] on them that should
be they don't laugh they only last a
couple of years especially if you wear
them out and dance in them but then
they'll start falling apart but those
are that's about the best you can get
for a guy but those are the those are
new rocks those are the gold standards
that was about 350 though yeah they are
considerably more expensive but he's had
those for years and years and years and
it's all real leather and they're just
Spanish made and I got two pair of these
but the other one has their shoes
I've had I've had some nice demonias
over the years usually like you know if
they're uh Shin High they're usually
about 90-ish 80 90 and then the
knee-high ones are usually like 110 120
and you can get like some real nice ones
with real like cool buckles and [ __ ]
like that but like I said if you wear
them out like pretty much every week and
dance in them and stuff about two years
later like the heels are gonna start
falling off so I got these boots on
black motorcycle pants and a black
T-shirt and just these right here and I
go to golf club like this
and run it it's like I run that [ __ ]
okay and um well it's you know on the
back everybody knows who I am well yeah
they know being Jan you know and then um
boots boots make the [ __ ] outfit it's
all built around Footwear
especially for dude yeah yeah
dude yeah because that's because dudes I
mean depending on what your look is but
I ca I kind of feel like dudes are
usually like more low-key they don't do
stuff quite as elaborate like I said
depending on what your deal is because
we do know some dudes that like super go
all out but you know mostly they're just
kind of gonna be like have some pants
like you got or maybe like a t-shirt or
just like a top or something they're not
going to have like super elaborate hair
or super elaborate makeup or something
like that you can get these boots
a [ __ ] Kilt and a black T-shirt and a
[ __ ] pipe and walk in there and
[ __ ] you'd be God that sounds like
the exact outfit that I've seen a couple
of people wear again
we have a couple yeah 50 60 like dressed
like that with a [ __ ] Pike yeah
there's one guy in particular that well
no two guys there's two guys in
particular they're older dudes yeah
um but distinguished looking older dudes
that you know they're they're real into
the kill game but the Kilts look good on
them I think yeah there is a kilt game
yeah you have to play The Kill game
play The Kill game
DJ Maniac said I have like five kills
yeah and he also said uh incorrect I
have five pairs of demonias I rotate
between and they're all still in great
shape maybe it was just the ones that I
had to remember I'm just harder on them
yeah we were dancing in them a lot and
we were wearing the same ones a lot yeah
because really I would only have like
one cool pair of them at a time to wear
them all the time so yeah after like a
couple of years like [ __ ] would start
falling off of there you'd have
demonia's shoes but you wore those not
in the club you wore those outside the
club
but no you I think there were 605s
demodia 605 so I think is what they were
called
they were the ones with just straps and
buckles going down the sides it's just
kind of a [ __ ] flat platform on the
bottom
lightweight foam kind of platform
they would mine would hold together it's
just that they were patent leather so
the [ __ ] start flaking off on the inside
yeah that too and it was there was a
zipper down the middle the zipper's held
though
um
Jenny would tear [ __ ] up though but it
was just dancing dancing in them
eventually they're rough on shoes yeah
eventually the [ __ ] the platform
would fall off the bottom like the glue
would give out and those uh those really
nice like Oxblood ones that I had
remember those platform ones with all
the buckles and stuff those
um I think the Heels state no no one of
the heels came off but then like the
other one the back of it like where the
heel is like busted out like the
stitching all came out yeah I don't know
why yeah is it you know they were like
my size or actually they were a size
bigger because I tend to get I wear a
seven but I tend to get eights when I
buy boots that go Olive just because I
have big calves so I usually get like a
bigger size so they'll so they won't be
super tight you had big calves yeah not
anymore no but I still like yeah some
room in that [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying still like some room in that [ __ ]
um let's see Zach says okay what should
you wear if you overheat easily
I don't know just like a fishnet shirt
probably
fishing with some pants if that would
only work with [ __ ] golf clothes and
you'd have to have the [ __ ] boots for
that yeah that's true just do yourself a
favor man [ __ ] go out and [ __ ] buy
yourself some golf boots some demonias
I mean you can make a goth outfit based
on that 100 110 bucks you can get
yourself into some goth boots which are
open uh they have an unlocked the The
Goth [ __ ] potential
then you start saying well what can I
throw together [ __ ] it'd just be like
some black jeans or some PVC jeans and
[ __ ] something like that you know you
could get [ __ ] off of Amazon or
that are like maybe velvet or something
most of my stuff is motorcycle oriented
because I ride bikes so I go for things
that I have dual purpose I could wear to
the club or I could [ __ ] ride on a
motorcycle with it
and they've got a lot of like sixty
dollar between the 40 to 60 dollar
[ __ ] motorcycle pants stuff and if
you get the if you know you know your
right size they're tight enough
because you don't want baggy [ __ ]
pants in a golf club you want they have
to be tight
um or fairly tight but you can't be so
tight that they'd [ __ ] split on a
motorcycle
um but so you you you can find stuff
that's kind of Dual Purpose and then
just uh black t-shirts of different
types
black muscle shirts black t-shirts black
compression [ __ ] tees whatever
anything like that that'd work yeah a
lot of guys generally just wear like
black band T-shirts yeah usually and
t-shirts and then um and then everything
everything after that is accessories
bracelets necklaces if your ears are
pierced different kinds of earrings
[ __ ] nose rings yeah hats different
kind of hats you can I always like kind
of like the industrial kind of
paramilitary kind of looking stuff
um
if you want to go the leather daddy
route you can go that way too you know
they'll have straight guys that'll wear
stuff like that in the god seed so it's
not really a gay thing like I said
everything's kind of unisex they don't
worry about that you know what I mean
[ __ ] me and my [ __ ] leather daddy
buddy [ __ ] kind of copy each other
some of the [ __ ] that we do you know
what I mean it doesn't have anything to
do with being gay well I think that was
what looks good one of the things that
always kind of like attracted me to the
god scene even back in the 80s was that
no one really gave us like you didn't no
like no I mean I have new people for
years and years like before that before
I knew they were gay
you just you didn't assume anything you
just you didn't think about it you were
just like whatever they were just like
that was another goth person a lot of
these [ __ ] young young people today
are wearing that [ __ ] on their sleeves
like that's the center of their identity
we [ __ ] we never did did that nobody
gave a [ __ ] who you were [ __ ] nobody
really cared it was just how cool you
were that was one thing that really
mattered
I mean unless you were [ __ ] the other
person's boyfriend yeah then they would
care yeah then they would care but other
than that okay
somebody without permission that you
cared about
DJ Maniac said depending on whether I'm
at an industrial themed or got themed
event I even change up my eyeshadow
black for goth dark gray for industrial
okay I I respect that I respect that
game and that's the thing I do kind of
try I don't know I feel like because
mannequins for example they they don't
do a theme every week but they do do a
lot of themes and like not a lot of
people participate but sometimes if I
remember like I'll do something more
along those lines but not usually like
usually because I really just have kind
of like a handful of outfits that I like
yeah yeah I forgot to mention that like
in uh if you're if you're kind of going
kind of full dress guys are going to be
wearing eyeliner
or a guy liner a guy call it I mean it's
just it's I can't that's also was in the
metal scene too you know Ozzy Osbourne
[ __ ] war and all those guys they wore
eyeliner when they went out
it looks good yeah it does yeah I
honestly I think I wish more guys would
wear eyeliner and I would and I wish
more guys would paint their nails I see
now that like uh I see now more guys
painting their nails and I like that and
I kind of wish that they would do like
if you've done that back in the 80s
everyone would have just you never would
have heard the end of it but like
nowadays you see it and it's not really
as big a deal and I kind of like that
because I don't know it looks cool it's
not black fingernails like I said
painting your nails or wearing eyeliner
that's not specifically like I haven't
done that in a long time I need to start
doing that's not like specifically a
woman thing I don't know why people
think that it's like I thought it was
seemed really dumb to me I haven't done
that in a long time yeah you still look
really good like with the eyeliner and
[ __ ] like that I know it's like a pain
in the ass and like you don't really
want it and I mostly was into liquid and
we don't have any liquid I gotta get
some liquor I do I have um I have [ __ ]
man
what do you think what do you think I
have an Amazon subscription that's right
every every couple weeks I get the big
fat liquid yeah eyeliner just a marker
yeah you know what I mean I have like I
have a thin one and I have like a whole
bunch of fat ones I like the liquid
markers the [ __ ] little Sharp
the sharp member of the sharp applicator
on the end yeah yeah like I said the
ones I have like they're just right in
there in the bathroom like I have a they
look like a marker it's like looks like
it's like it's not I mean it's thinner
than that yeah well it's kind of like
that yeah I could use the end if it's
kind of like I'd go full Anton LaVey
yeah Diego Anton was wearing that [ __ ]
too because like I said it looks good it
makes your eyes look better bigger it
makes like your eyes stand out like from
your face eyes are never big I got what
they call Hunter eyes
no they got Hunter eyes and prey eyes
prey eyes around Hunter eyes are the
little [ __ ]
almond shaped squinty eyes I got a
squinty eyes
I don't know what kind of that's why I
have that's why you love me is it
[ __ ] right because I had those eyes
I had those no you know what it was it
wasn't anything to do with your eyes do
you know what one of the things that I
really used to like about I mean other
than like you dress cool and like you
could dance and everything like that
which like I said a lot of straight guys
can't dance so that's like a big plus
yeah
um I like the way you smelled yeah
it was an obsession yeah but I and I if
somebody else was wearing Obsession it
might not work the same but just like
with your body chemistry or whatever I
just really that was like a really
appealing
uh smell you know what I mean I wore
Obsession I still wear it she gives it
to me yeah like whenever you see me
stocked up on it I can't be stuck up
because I like the smell yeah well I
like the smell of it on you yeah
Obsession for Men yes Zach knows all
about having obsessions
it kind of has a kind of a spicy vanilla
kind of a FL kind of a smell to it yeah
it smells good and if you use it
regularly it [ __ ] permeates pretty
much all your clothes all your clothes
so you kind of always smell like that
well yeah I mean some like you could
even you know back when we first started
going out like in your closet like all
your clothes smelled like that too and I
was like oh
like it smelled the only one I like is
Fahrenheit I used to wear that one I
don't remember with that one Toby Toby
wears Fahrenheit
oh okay all right the daddy boy I'm kind
of remembering like yeah he always
smokes he wears Fahrenheit he always
smells good yeah I just didn't know it I
think I asked him one time what that was
it's kind of reminiscent of obsession
yeah they kind of go together pretty
well
I've worn them both they're they're both
good but I haven't had I haven't worn
Fahrenheit in a [ __ ] long long time
he still wears that
that was those were 90s fragrances yeah
but they got it right they smelled
[ __ ] really good
I mean they're very masculine there
might be different ones nowadays that
like are good but I don't know I don't
there's actually a thing
um
what what's the matter looking at that
thing she's like why is the fan on yeah
I don't like it it's been on
she's like yeah but I'm just now getting
upset about it
that was the 90s fragrances for men
smelled masculine but they didn't stick
yeah they they weren't too some of that
[ __ ] had too much musk in it I kind of
like a little bit I like a muskie
kind of yeah but you don't want too much
well now remember how karate was from
the 60s karate and 60s you remember
karate I do remember it but I don't
remember what it smells like I can't I
can't recall it I remember it was a big
guy I remember it was a big thing I tend
to have I don't know like I don't know a
lot about different um perfumes and
scents and things like that like I get
every now and then because I have that
um that little like sample cosmetic
Subscription Service Ipsy and so they
send you like five or six different like
little samples of things like every
month
and sometimes they send fragrances and a
couple of those I've really really liked
do you think I can remember the name of
them of course not uh so I could buy a
bigger one but honestly like
um the only scent that I really really
liked because I felt like a lot of the
women's perfumes even though like I said
they're done that's dumb it's like again
that it's a it's a smell it should just
kind of be
a unisex I kind of feel like but um I
don't know I kind of feel like ones that
were marketed toward women were like too
flowery I don't really like super
flowery ones unless it's
um like an orange blossom kind of smell
I do like that but I tend to like ones
that are not necessarily spicy but I do
like kind of like muskier ones or
vanilla or wood or something like that I
tend to like stuff like that maniacs and
Tom just wear Sex Panther to the club it
smells like Bigfoot's dick
yeah yeah somebody had asked if I'd seen
Barbarian no I didn't see it no I
watched it I thought it was great was it
good I thought it was great I have to
see it I don't
probably like it yeah I liked it because
um
and like I said and every single person
that has reviewed it says this it's like
it's better if you don't know anything
about what it's about don't tell me
anything about it like before you see it
because because you will have no idea
where the [ __ ] it's going don't tell me
anything about it and it's like super
entertaining to like watch where the
[ __ ] it's going don't tell me anything
about it I want to know
um hello Dave what's going on hello you
both all here just going are you going
to mannequins later we might we might go
we might we're thinking about it
Zach said did you say you wear cologne
Jenny sometimes I do like if I'm going
out I'll usually do it like for a long
time when I was younger
um my very fan I don't even know if they
make this anymore but my very favorite
uh scent was called design I don't even
remember doing makes it she's just
tearing books out yeah
um I just really really like that smell
but I like like I said I kind of like
more
earthy scents or like musky sense I do
like real sweet stuff like um if it's
sweet like vanilla cookie and stuff I
like that kind of smells too for me it
has to be a mixture it has to be a
mixture of stuff I I kind of like
some musk but it has to be offset
with something kind of
herbal or something kind of sweet like I
really liked
a lot of people don't like Patchouli I
like Patchouli I do too I like Patchouli
I know it got it got unfairly associated
with hippies yeah I liked uh
frankincense and myrrh smell yeah I like
that too I liked um anything that smells
kind of like vanilla yeah
um especially if it's kind of offset
with something else there was one called
White musk it was for women it was oh I
remember that's kind of neutral I like
that one
um no but leave it alone stop tearing up
books she's looking at me like I can do
it though man
said you could no come on I'm gonna make
her a little bitty t-shirt
she's coming over here that's okay she's
like Daddy yelled at me okay don't yell
at her stretch out relax I try to tell
Daddy not to yell at her because she she
doesn't no it doesn't matter because
she's never really been she does she's
never been hit or anything like that
[ __ ] it I smacked her on the ass one
time and she looked at me like what was
that she didn't even understand it was
punishment
what was that yeah because I mean we've
had her since she was a baby
she was tiny tiny in the same bed with
us yeah she was that big her eyes were
still blue when we got her I think she
was only four five or six weeks she was
the size of a small squirrel yeah
sleeping in the bed with us
yeah
but see that's these people yeah but she
took to us immediately which I thought
was like really cool because like I said
and I think we've said this before but
in case you guys weren't here one time
um she was basically
um a friend of the family
apparently I don't really know what the
real story is but apparently this woman
found Pookie in her backyard and like
her dog
um was menacing the poor little baby and
I guess baby pookie was I guess her mom
abandoned her so she was just left in
this woman's backyard that's the story
that we got anyway I think the letter
was just broken up maybe maybe that's
just the story
um maybe it would like to make her seem
like more pitiful so he would but as
soon as she sent us a picture I was like
oh we're taking this little because her
little gray face and like I said she had
blue eyes back then because all kittens
do like up to a certain age and um so we
brought her home
and she was in her little carrier and
she came out and she was kind of like
what I mean she was so so small with
that tiny little tail and everything and
she comes out with her little butt
wiggle in and then Beijing of course
comes in and goes like I don't like this
and uh and then Pookie like came over
and like got my lap and was like is
everything okay and I'm just like yeah
it's cool we didn't know what her name
was at that point it took us a long time
to name her actually
Pookie isn't even really her real name
that was just like a nickname that we
started calling her and then like that
just became her name because I was like
she just seems like a Pookie to me yeah
and I'm thinking and I named her
actually that I was thinking of
Garfield's teddy bear like from the from
the strip because she could because she
kind of looks like a teddy bear the name
that she they gave us under was some
kind of African name that we forgot I
mean I don't even remember what they had
named here it didn't suit her no and it
was it was a boy's name they thought it
was a boy they thought the kitten was a
boy yeah even though we only had her for
a day or two and Tom was like that's
that's a girl
even though she was little and it's hard
to tell like when they're that small but
yeah like her personality that was a
girl yeah but then the thing is it's
like the very like I think the day after
we got her
um she jumped up on the bed and like
kind of looked at us like that yeah and
we just like looked at her and like
looked at each other and looked at the
cat and we did a thing where she looked
at us and we looked at each other and
then she looked both of us like we're
all looking around like who is this and
she was like okay they're okay you guys
are Mommy and Daddy all right yeah I
guess so yeah that was like the morning
after we got her and we're like okay and
she just like slept in the bed slept
into bed she was like this big yeah
yeah
she's hilarious she's hilarious
yeah grandpa said whenever I smell
Patchouli I think of a dirty hippie
chick trying to cover up her UTI yeah I
kind of feel like that's uh it's it gets
unfairly is because I actually really
like that smell now we have a friend now
every time I smell Patchouli yeah you
know who I think of I don't know
um I associate it with like hot goth
chicks in Detroit late 80s and then
early 90s second later on so you know if
I can or mid 90s when I got out of the
army there were a lot of Goths girls
that wore that I think of our
veterinarian friend
oh yeah yeah yeah the nipple Grabber
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know because he always wears
Patchouli but it always like smells
really good I think yeah that was a
popular goth fragrance it was yeah
um
so was frankincense and myrrh and
dragon's blood and [ __ ] like they had
different oh dragon's blood that's
another one I used to buy the um yeah
that essential oil from the witchcraft
store yeah they'd wear anything they got
out of the damn witchcraft shops they'd
wear that because their whole shop
smelled like that and I was like oh my
God that smells amazing I even had like
the little purple cones yeah of incense
that smelled like that so I could make
my whole room smell like that like when
I was yeah 80s 80s and 90s goth girls
[ __ ] kind of had it down they were
they were kind of cornered in the market
on that it was part Wicca part BDSM part
punk rock yeah and uh there was a lot of
Lady Death references and all kinds of
[ __ ] you know uh [ __ ] Susie in the
bed she's like Susie [ __ ] fashion
cues and you still start it's coming
back you know a lot of these young girls
wearing death Rock
in Goth Rock and death Rock Fashion now
they're bringing it back
that makes me very happy yeah that makes
me very I'll show you guys an example
what I'm talking about Zach says I'm
also someone who likes the smell of
gasoline and burning fall leaves I bet
that can make an interesting cologne
smell I'm not much I don't much love the
smell of gasoline but I really do love
the smell of burning fall leaves and I
really do love the smell of like burning
matches I like that kind of like silver
smell
there's got to be some kind of like
cologne that has a smell like that
I read a couple books one time about
mixing colognes and there's all kind of
stuff in there that you wouldn't like
think would be in a cologne like
molecule like poop molecules and stuff
because it gives it you know like an
earthy kind of
um kind of smell to it you know what I
mean some of the [ __ ] comes from like
really gross sources is All I'm gonna
say
I always show this girl because she
really kind of has can't has it down she
goes under the name on on um on
Instagram as clumsy succubus but that's
like very much 90s this looks like
was it lady death or no what was the
name of that character
she was a comic book character she had
that same look
yeah remember what I think it was Lady
Death wasn't it yeah I think so that was
that uh wouldn't it Neil games yeah yeah
yeah that would be like a very basic
kind of look
she rocks that kind of stuff
that's going back to the 90s
um show you some classic
that's 80s as [ __ ]
yeah DJ Maniac said the death Rock scene
is Undead and well here in New York City
and they're all at least 20 years
younger than me which is great yeah I
remember because I was at um the drop
dead Festival in New York City back in
whenever they had it there like I went
there like two years in a row might have
been like 2009 2010 something like that
and yeah it was like really cool to see
that so I kind of feel like there was
like a death Rock Revival like in the
late 2000s and you're kind of seeing it
again now I don't know so much with the
music but with the look for sure yeah I
don't know what they listened to they
must be listening to the to death rock
type music maybe I'm not real sure
because you know like I said it's it's
just the look that I see a lot nowadays
like we even see like some kids like 20
ish year olds at Memento Mori and stuff
like that that are rocking like the
death row well I know she listens to
Sisters of Mercy because she has a first
and last and always tattoo on her arm oh
okay but that's but here right here I
always like to show this picture of her
this is just full [ __ ] drag
that's fantastic
look right there what what year would
you put that in
91.89
yeah probably around that time
crafter said everyone smells like
marijuana in Michigan now that it's
legal see it like marijuana doesn't
smell good
unfortunately
man we were at the Halloween party and
well the thing about it is that
mannequins like it has this enclosed
patio like I didn't talk too much about
it I'm just saying but it's like you
know every now and then somebody'd walk
by and be like whoa
weed all right weed technically is
illegal here in Florida still still but
there isn't a big penalty for it and
there don't seem to be enforcing
anything they don't care
Zach says I love the smell of pot it
always makes me hungry I don't like this
though I hate weed I'm not a big fan of
it like maybe it's just because I've
never had any good [ __ ] that's what
everybody says but yeah it's not any
good I don't yeah it's not really my
thing man you can't compare to LSD it's
nowhere near as driving as cocaine
it doesn't knock you out as hard as say
morphine it's just it's a it's a middle
of the road kind of a [ __ ] drug it's
a
it's always kind of made me feel like
um
you feel kind of unsettled sometimes you
know what I mean it's like you're
you think people might be watching you
you get a little slightly paranoid
it's nowhere near as good as alcohol I
think alcohol is a lot better
well alcohol is a lot more fun I didn't
really have much fun when I did yeah
when I smoked weed I smoked a lot of
weed and it's not that good
like I said every it just made me even
more like anxious and like feeling like
everyone was looking at me I'm like yeah
I don't need that I already feel like
that I don't need like something that
hands that up you can smoke a lot of it
to where you can almost hallucinate but
it's nowhere near as good as LSD
Jeffy art said the image of Pookie and
Tom interacting reminds me of the
cartoon dog Marc Anthony and his kitten
[ __ ] foot yeah I mean
she's a daddy's girl for real I mean she
loves Mommy too I'm not saying that I
think she loves us both equally she
loves us for different reasons she loves
Daddy because he wrestles with her and
she likes to wrestle she's a tomboy
David's complimenting you
where down there am I oh I'm like way up
back here
um
Dave said oh it doesn't compare to how
Jen dresses she has got the goth look
down thank you very much thank you very
much yeah she does but but the thing is
is that Jen's Jen's got off this
contemporary that one chick's got this
retro yeah I think that's pretty cool
yeah I kind of like well I prefer the
Retro look honestly
um you know but like I said it's just
funny to see retro on a 20 something
but it makes me happy yeah it makes me
happy yeah that I that I can see that
like I said if they're listening to cool
[ __ ] music then that's [ __ ]
awesome she's definitely a fan of old
sisters yeah see that's good
in a way it's almost kind of like I
think we got into this when we were
talking about
um you know our friend Nick who was like
21. and he's super into like oh gee
loves Christian death and 45 Grave he
loves all that kind of stuff Joy
Division and um and I'm almost kind of
like jealous because it's like he gets
to experience it like for the first time
you know what I mean because for us it's
like I still love all that stuff but
it's like you know it's been around for
like 40 years or whatever hold on no she
oh she um
has a YouTube channel and she sings
um classic goth music
she was singing um cure
Kyoto song yeah so no she listens to the
same music with us oh okay yeah that's
gonna makes me feel not so old now
makes me feel not so old yeah
um Bob Apple said I really enjoyed
Cabinet of Curiosities on Netflix uh
mashup of Creep Show and lovecraftian
good horror Anthology I'm actually like
in the middle of watching that I think
I've watched the first five or six
episodes and I'm probably gonna do like
on my other channel which is called
scare Salon I'm gonna do like a
video about it when I finish watching it
oh and by the way if anybody uh watches
my scarcelon channel I'm doing I'm
working on a video where I'm reviewing
all the VHS movies like all five of them
um and it's gonna go up tomorrow I hope
but I'm kind of behind on it like I
watched the first three movies and like
wrote reviews of those and then I'm
almost done with the fourth one and then
like tomorrow morning I have to get up
and watch the fifth one which I haven't
seen yet and write a thing and then like
record the video but it should be up
tomorrow it just might not be as early
as I usually put videos up on Saturday
that's all I'm saying because I'm still
working on it I thought I would have
more time to watch five movies but you
know I didn't I'm almost done with four
though but I mean VHS 94 I've already
seen it so it's not that
you know difficult but I'm almost done
with that and then tomorrow morning I
have to get up and watch VHS 99 which I
haven't seen yet
uh Dave says gotta go hope to see you
guys tonight all right see you later
hopefully yeah we'll go out we probably
will I mean
now that you're talking about it I'm
like yeah maybe that'd probably be fun
like I said I did like going out on
Halloween but yeah we couldn't really
and it was kind of it was kind of sucky
because like when we first got down
there we thought at first we were gonna
have to come back home because we could
have found any [ __ ] place to park so
we were kind of in a bad mood because we
were like driving around we couldn't
find a place to park because it was a
zillion [ __ ] people
but you know
uh Danny Rowling said did you ever see
the film cabin in the woods and if so
did you like it I saw it I really liked
it I don't think Tom has seen it though
here's some cool pictures of Jen
yeah that's old uh 10 years
oh
yeah her friend Tony took those yeah
I still have that headpiece actually
although it looks a little bit more
raggedy than that nowadays yeah do you
still have that top
um no but I have one like that yeah we
need to get you some more of those
I have one that's like that but it's not
the exact same one like the one that I
have now has like buckles on the bottom
now those shoes are demonia
yeah those shoes have fallen apart yeah
they're gone now like the the they were
cool I had them a long time actually we
got those second hand
and I had them a while but then like the
heels started falling off all the time
this is classic gym
oh you [ __ ] up the lighter it's okay
actually it's going to go back to that
anyway because I'm trying to that was a
great outfit
oh this might have been those boots yeah
those are those ones they're gone now
yeah well the back busted out yeah
is this thing gonna
come on
there we go yeah like I said our friend
Tony took that yeah
although we produced them
he just took he just took the pictures
yeah
okay that's driving me nuts come on
it's too bright
oh that was like this picture it now you
just reset it
always like this one
yeah that came out good actually yeah
oh [ __ ]
you spilled it right on the [ __ ]
right on the books and right on the she
tore that book up though
right on the um all right plug
it
not much fell out
it was almost empty anyway
this is another cute one I kept I've
always been paranoid about that table I
knew that was gonna happen
almost looks like a Betty Page photo
shoot
foreign
okay
I'm already getting a response there
she's gorgeous good for you brother
um
okay
uh Mrs Evans already party said God damn
that's driving me crazy
um ooh Jenny loved your reviews of Ricky
tikki-tavi and watch her in the woods
yeah I remembered everybody wanted me to
do more like kid stuff and I wanted to
do that as well uh I will definitely be
doing Return to Oz at some point because
I haven't seen that in a million years
and that's one that usually comes up a
lot sorry I'm doing this but it's super
bright and it's driving me crazy there
we go that fixed it
uh Danny Rowling says vhs2 the zombie
Baphomet and alien stories are the best
and terrifying kinda
um yeah I mean the second one was good I
think I still think the first one's the
best I haven't seen uh 99 yet though uh
gonna
I don't know the third one
um which I watched earlier I really did
not like but I think a lot of people
don't like the third one VHS viral
but you know I'll I'll record that
section how do you walk around those
boots uh look man if you got to answer
that question then you can't those are
not those are not um
those are actually like pretty
comfortable honestly yeah Jen look
nothing really Spilled Out of that
well other than that but yeah that's not
even a [ __ ] that's not even a quarter
of a cup
Hugo said Jenny you should post the
episodes of your new channels on
Facebook also I do usually like um I
usually cross post them to several of my
different like I'll post them on my
personal page I post them on scare Salon
I post them on my author page I usually
post them on the 30 13 o'clock page too
praise Rama yeah that's what I was just
watching that like earlier like about an
hour ago like before we started the show
so you know
and
are those buns called Princess Leia's
they could be they're actually little
Chinese things I remember correctly
weren't they
what are you talking about the little
[ __ ] um parts of that headdress that
had those [ __ ] buns things I bought
them out the black girl hair store yeah
but weren't they kind of just like some
kind of a Chinese uh
I thought it was like a Chinese little
round puff ball that had hair
braided around it wasn't it I forgot
what they look like no it's just a bun I
mean it was just what
okay it was basically just something to
like pull your own hair back if you
didn't have that much hair and like put
another thing and then slap the the bun
on top of it I just had two of those and
I hot glued them too yeah to um
headbands headband that's right and then
like I had some other kind of like hair
that I just like bought separate and
like I braided it and stuff like that a
lot of that super impressive goth hair
that you see those girls have a lot of
that's extensions and hair pieces and
things that clip in it's it's not all
hair
yeah it never was the real elaborate
[ __ ] it never was you know
wigs with [ __ ] things attached inside
the wigs and
some of its hair but some of it isn't
some of it's her hair and some of it
isn't
yeah I mean that
particular thing there
um some of that's my actually like the
bangs and stuff because this is my
actual hair I don't have anything in
here right now so this is my actual hair
but um that picture like the bangs or my
hair and like the back part was my hair
but the buns and the stripes right here
like with the white that was fake yeah
and that was on a headband yeah I just
hot glued everything to like a headband
so you just like put it on so it looks
like hair but I think there might have
been a wig in there too though wouldn't
it no it wasn't okay no
it was just like I said there was a
headband with hair attached to it yeah
that's all and you know they're they're
kind of easy to make if you have the
time but you know I don't have a lot of
time so
I think I still have somewhere around
here like big packs of different colors
of hair but I just don't have time to
like [ __ ] you know make all that
stuff
Mark says which one had the insane cult
story in it that was in the um in the
second one
that was in the second one and that was
like um what what's the matter
what she wants attention what's the
matter baby yeah she's like I'm gonna
tear some [ __ ] up right now
that was the same director like that
Indonesian guy that did
um the one from VHS 94 like the super
bloodbathy one you know what I mean they
were like kind of similar
I'll probably get into this like on my
video whenever it goes up it's probably
gonna go up tomorrow sometime hopefully
um but you know I got a little bit
behind because I was like of course I
thought that I could watch and review
like five movies like before the weekend
and I was like what the [ __ ] was I
thinking so it's like all day like I
watched one yesterday
and then you know wrote a thing for that
and then I watched like three
yeah I watched part two part three and
most of part four like today and like
wrote and in between like I wrote about
them but I still have to watch the fifth
one
so I don't know like when and then that
then I have to record the video and edit
it and then get like get it put up so I
don't know what time it'll be but it'll
hopefully be tomorrow sometime I'll get
up early unless we go out and we're out
until four o'clock in the morning in
which case
you know it might be a little bit later
than uh usual but we'll see
we'll see I'm just like I feel bad
because I always I get in a routine of
like putting videos up at like
particular times like on every day but
then I think to myself it's like well
have to like put it up at that time it's
like as long as I get it up on that day
then that's fine I don't have to like
put it up at a particular time so it's
just me like imposing on myself imposing
on myself
Ben says someone was telling me last
night about a friend who buys eyelashes
not sure if real or plastic in Vietnam
for a couple cents each and sells them
for 10 bucks to beauticians uh and makes
100K a year I mean probably
although the thing about I don't know
like um you can buy like pretty cheap
[ __ ]
uh fake eyelashes but
I guess like for the really good [ __ ]
where you have to go in there and get
somebody to like put them in like one
hair at a time or one little [ __ ]
thing at a time
I just can't I admire like girls that
can wear fake eyelashes like every
single day because I don't know what it
is but it's like I'll wear them when I
go out sometimes but a lot of times I'm
just like I can't get them to [ __ ]
stick and I don't know like what the
secret is so a lot of times like I'm
sitting there like trying to [ __ ]
stick it on there and like sticking more
glue in there and the Like Glue is going
in my eye and then like it sticks to my
finger and it like comes off and it's
it's a [ __ ] show it's a [ __ ] show like
sometimes it comes out okay but same
thing happens when I'm putting like fake
nails on
like oh he's gonna try to put I have
ones on right now but a lot of times I
could put him around like oh [ __ ] I
stuck my fingers together or something
you know what I mean you know what I did
earlier is that one of these nails came
off and so I was like gluing it back on
and then before the glue was dry I
didn't realize but I was typing and I
got glue evidently on my a key on my
keyboard so now my a key is
so
so now when I type I have to skip the A
and I have to like copy paste an a from
somewhere else because it's because the
[ __ ] key is stuck down so you know
uh DJ Maniac said I can hear the cat
growling yeah she's um she's mad she's
very upset one because we're not paying
attention to her and two because the
ceiling fan is on yeah she does not like
that ceiling fan it's moving it's
wobbling as it's spinning and she sees
it move and she doesn't like it and she
doesn't like it and the funny thing too
is that like I said after the show if
you turn it off then she still sits
there under it and like stares at it
like suspiciously for like a really long
time like yelling at it like because I
guess she's like waiting for it to come
back on because I keep teasing her about
like maybe there's a ghost up there
foreign
Richard Brown said did you ever see the
BBC TV series League of gentlemen I did
not
I did not
uh let's see what else do do
you see I said I do the same thing like
I'm glad that you guys can hear the cat
making noise because I didn't I wasn't
sure if like the microphone was picking
her up because she was way down there by
the floor American Military 100 says I
motivated him to start HRT that's good
did you start it already or you just
said I'm gonna do it because you haven't
started until you started until you do
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
because Tom it's like when he gets into
something he'll be like an evangelist
about it she don't mind me talking he's
an event she does not want me [ __ ] no
I was thinking diving men from the
junkyard yeah that's not true okay
that's not true yeah that's what will
happen to you after 38 you'll slowly go
into the junkyard so you might as well
just [ __ ] go ahead and just
swallow your pride and start ejecting
that [ __ ] you'll make a comeback quick
Evan from Evan from ludovico Technique
we saw him last week he just [ __ ]
can't believe it yeah we hadn't seen him
in a long time dude I've never [ __ ]
seen you like this
and he's
40 something now
and he goes man I work out and I get
weaker and I said yeah yeah he goes what
I'm seeing here is this this is
impossible without
without [ __ ] outside [ __ ]
assistance right and I said yeah this is
biotech this is totally impossible and
he goes I can't believe it you know it's
it's
impossible
Dave Rowling said someone should make a
burbs too but with the neighbors being a
covenant of witches would be cool I you
know what I love I love The Burbs and I
wish more people uh had seen it but
yeah I kind of feel I'm surprised they
never like remade it I'm glad they
didn't but because it wouldn't have
worked I don't think it would work the
same like with a different cast or
anything like that because so much of
that had to do with uh Tom Hanks and
like the other people that were in it
you know what I mean but they could do
like a they could do a part two I would
probably watch that yeah HRT is hormone
replacement yep
went down the wrong pipe oh
went down the wrong pipe
goodness
um yeah Richard Brown said Joe Dante is
so good he really is I mean and I feel
like that's maybe one of his more
underrated movies you don't really hear
that many people talking about it
nowadays
The Burbs and The Money Pit are the same
movie to me because I've never seen
either one through I like the Money Pit
also that's another one that it's like
maybe
I'm pretty sure we reviewed the burbs
didn't we review The Burbs I think we
did I don't think we did Money Pit
though and I always like really liked
The Money Pit it's funny because it was
one of those movies that was on cable
like all the time back so I probably saw
it like a million times so there's like
lines from it that are still
stuck in my brain like even after all
this time which The Burbs has that too
like the whole thing about all where
they go in like the the clopex house or
whatever and like there's all these
pictures around and people are asking
like who their family members were and
the guy goes came with the frame like I
still remember that but like from The
Money Pit the one thing that I remember
is like the one the douchey guy
like uh going up to the guy painting the
house and he's just like and he's like
showing him how to paint paint don't
tickle I don't know why I remember that
but you know what I mean that's one of
those things
um new cast mostly older dead yeah I
mean that was a long time ago yeah you
reviewed the birds I thought we had I
thought we had but we haven't done money
pit though I mean that's not a horror
movie but it's like a comedy about
buying a house and then like it
slowly draining all of your money away
which you know
that's what would happen I would love to
see a Halloween 3 season of The Witch
part two I think we were talking about
this a while back you remember that how
we were saying like maybe that should be
like its own kind of like franchise
like Halloween three yeah
I kind of yeah there's a lot of
potential there like there's a in the
mythology you know what I mean
I and we kind of talked about this when
we talked about Halloween 3 too because
I was kind of like well as much as yeah
everybody like liked Michael Myers and
it's a slasher thing and whatever the
[ __ ] but um I did kind of like John
Carpenter's original idea where he's
just like well we're just gonna put out
a new movie every year that's like just
Halloween related but it doesn't
necessarily have to do with the same
storyline so I kind of liked that but
that said I think that there's more that
they could explore you know what I mean
with Halloween 3. that was like a much
bigger
concept
and you could like do something with
that
and I'm surprised nobody has or at least
not not that I know of I would have made
a whole series of movies on that were a
mini series that's what I mean you
totally could I mean maybe somebody has
it's entirely possible in this day and
age because there's so many streaming
services and so many people are making
movies and
I find out about you like even movies I
loved or books I loved or something like
that [ __ ] man like sometimes I find out
there's an adaptation or somebody made a
whole [ __ ] mini-series about it or
something and I didn't even know about
it so what's up book I'm I'm you know
somebody could have made one
um would we ever consider reviewing the
1989 Tim Burton Batman film yeah yeah we
probably could sure wait that's right we
haven't done that have we we've done
other Timbers good movies but we've done
I remember liking it I haven't seen it
in a long time was good too like I said
I'm not like a big like
comic book movie person so it's just
kind of like it's not usually something
I would seek out but I remember like
really liking them I think there were uh
two in that Universe right first one the
second one
right well he didn't do a third one
I don't think Tim Burton
and he just did the one but I could be
wrong I thought he did the second one
too maybe
now I can't but it is that same I
thought it was that same basic Universe
though it might have been
I think I lose track because there have
been so many like different versions and
different reboots and
I totally not as bad as Spider-Man like
I totally can't keep track of that but
Batman
there have been a bunch of Batmans too
yeah the best one was the one with the
Batman Begins and then the other two or
three movies with you know
Heath Ledger and all well that's Chris
it wasn't what the Christopher Nolan
ones Christopher Nolan once yeah they
were Yeah Tim Burton did too okay you
did too yeah I thought he just did that
one shows what I know but like I said
I'm not real big in the like I like Tim
Burton but I'm not real into like comic
books Tim Burton was gonna do a Superman
yeah they uh they scrapped it and it had
what's his name in it
Nicholas Cage was gonna play Superman
yeah that's I even know about that like
that's that's kind of famous I saw
photographs of what they were working on
it looked goofy as [ __ ] but I think it
might have been okay they look Goofy
yeah who was it that directed The the
much reviled uh Batman and Robin I don't
know that was a piece of [ __ ]
the one with like Mr Freeze yeah it had
it had Arnold did it
it was it just got more and more
ridiculous
but you know some people have said well
it was kind of going back to the
television series and in the early 60s
yeah this series was kind of like that I
kind of feel like I don't know I kind of
feel like maybe you could get away with
that nowadays
maybe no the script was too [ __ ]
flimsy it is just [ __ ] crazy no I
mean not that specific movie but you
could get away with oh we're doing
Batman but we're doing it like the Adam
West series like we're doing all campy
yeah like if you said that was your
intention from the outset people would
be like okay they'd be on board I feel
like wouldn't mind having that on DVD
that Series yeah yeah
Joel Schumacher that's it was same guy
that did Lost Boys and falling down
which those two movies were good so I
don't really know what the [ __ ] happened
there
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
there
Nicholas Cage and a robotic spider
mm-hmm
Mark says the new Interview with the
Vampire show has been cool yeah I've
heard that that's really good I'm
actually gonna do
um the first the first uh episode is
available to watch on for free on
shutter so I'm gonna watch it like one
of these days and if it's good then I
could I think it's on AMC right like
don't you have to have AMC to watch it I
can find it
but I've heard it's good so I'll I'll go
over there and check it out
let's see yeah see like Joel Schumacher
did some good [ __ ] he did Batman Forever
and Batman and Robin
yeah go figure with that nipple armor
I mean
here's the thing about every and I
always think of this like when when a
movie has like some really clearly some
poor decisions like on on the screen
um it wasn't like one person just made
that movie and was like Hey nipple armor
like that's their fetish or whatever
this is a a huge undertaking with like
hundreds and hundreds of people involved
you would think that somebody at some
point along the way would be like you
know I kind of feel like that's a dumb
idea you know what I mean and or maybe
more than one person like if if there
was if it was a just World a lot of
people would have just said no I think
that's a stupid idea and they'd be like
yeah maybe we shouldn't do that but
the fact that you can get that many
people to just like go along with that
that blows my mind that blows my mind
ah I don't get it I don't get it like
why
I mean even from a practicality
standpoint why would armor have nipples
on it anyway
I mean there's no reason for that like
sure like if you want to be like stuff
like I said it's more like a fetishistic
thing which if that's what your movie
was about
then no one would question it but it's
like if you're supposed to be a
superhero and you're supposed to be
fighting crime
and [ __ ] like that
I kind of feel like nipples on this is
just I don't know it just seems like
really impractical
or useless at best I mean you know
impractical at worst
Jeffy Hart said to its credit did have
some homoerotic undertones
yeah okay I don't so you know what I
think I maybe I don't even know if I've
seen the whole thing like all the way
through
now because like I said I'm not really
inclined to like watch superhero movies
anyway
um so I may have seen like bits and
pieces of it on cable over the years but
it's not like something that I would
actually like have sat down and watched
and like paid attention to you know what
I'm saying
so
no they're talking about Wild Wild West
I heard that was a [ __ ] show also but I
don't think I've seen that all the way
through either
unless I did and I just forgot about it
Jeff yard said maybe Schumacher was
trying to go for the Roman Centurion
look maybe
that's how he justified it to everybody
I'm not really sure what are you talking
about nipples on the armor
well the Japanese did that in all their
comic books
but see but that's what I'm saying I'm
just kind of like from a practicality
standpoint like why would you even need
that
the only reason you would need that is
if you were doing like you said like a
comic book something is lit was like
fetishistic like you just wanted it to
look cool or look sexy or something like
that it looks sexy then yeah you would
put numbers on it but if you were a real
life superhero fighting crime you
wouldn't put nipples on like you
wouldn't even think of that they wanted
it to look like a real muscular people
wearing wearing unitards
look like that you could see through
thing that you come across with
um you know you're kind of like sword
and sorcery kind of stuff like your
Frank Rosetta kind of stuff it's like if
you're gonna have like a Female warrior
or something like that it's like oh
she's got armor but it's like a bra and
like a [ __ ] like a little bitty I'm
like maybe she might want some better
armor than that if she's gonna be like
fighting ogres and [ __ ] like that are
you going I'm not going into battle in
like a [ __ ] leather bikini or some
[ __ ] Batman Batman's armor and
everything in that that's just to head
ABS on it it had ABS it had x on it okay
it had ribs well then you could just be
like kind of a fat ass underneath and
you could just like just slam it on and
be like yeah yeah put the [ __ ]
nipples
[Laughter]
look like
see now that's that's something I would
say they should have gone Whole Hog with
that I mean if they were gonna go like
nipples on the armor they should be back
there on pubic hair dicks yeah just put
the dick on there put the little
put a little mushroom head on there
that's [ __ ] hilarious a little
Mushroomhead
Apple put an apple on there
no
speaking of which we started we started
doing sex talk and we get sex spots yeah
the sex bots [ __ ] heard that [ __ ] so
far popping in you know what a lot of
people in there for Ben said we they had
this crazy Cod pieces too we should do a
show just about copies yeah we should do
a show just about cotton pieces because
man back in the day there were some
[ __ ] crazy ones I saw church was
trying to stop them I saw someone back
in the day that had like [ __ ] Wings
on them and all kind of crap
church is trying to stop him he said
those Cloud pieces were getting too bad
[ __ ] big
funny when you think about it well
because you know about like back in the
day like what was it like the 1700s or
whatever it was when they had this like
super big like elaborate wigs it's like
look I have a [ __ ] ship in mind and
all this it has goldfish in it or
whatever the [ __ ] and it's like I don't
know if they did that but like I have
seen ones with like shits in them but
yeah they did kind of like the whole
thing with the Cod pieces too where they
just got more and more ridiculous yeah
and like they had like [ __ ] animal
heads coming out of there and like
[ __ ] bat wings or you know Eagle
wings
the women were also using like bodices
and anything to pop their [ __ ]
titties out through the top and they
they tried to make their boobs look as
big and as [ __ ] scrunched in there as
they could
and the only thing you couldn't see was
the nipple
they they yeah I mean the dresses came
like right down to like yeah you see the
top of the areola a little bit yeah and
I they must have been doing some
gymnastics to twist things around
because it would be real [ __ ] full on
the top and then there was no no nipple
but it should have been there where was
it so much [ __ ] tucked it yeah I
wondered did they have like boob tape
back then did they like because you know
how like at Fashion well nowadays they
like tape everything in place so it
doesn't move around like where it's not
supposed to There Was You know the
misconception that
the past was uh [ __ ]
in the west at least there's a
misconception that the past was prudish
and it wasn't
the Medieval Era and the in the
Renaissance Era was [ __ ] Wild
the 1700s was a sexual Revolution
people don't realize that a lot of out
of wedlock stuff going on and [ __ ]
threesomes and
nudity nudism lots of that
um
there was homosexuality and lesbianism
just that that wasn't quite out but it
was a lot of it and this is a the
Marquita Assad wrote about it well he
worried about everything what about
[ __ ] wait seriously if you thought of
something marquisite already thought of
it and wrote about it in great detail I
kind of trust the Marquis writings in a
certain way he explained how he became a
sadist
he was gonna be he's gonna join the
church he was religious when he was a
kid but then he found out his brother
got in there before he did his older
brother and he found out how corrupt it
was
that they were basically just [ __ ]
poonhounds [ __ ] and the the nuns and
the priests and all the orphanages and
all everything that the whole thing was
just this a den of [ __ ] sexual
depravity
uh in France
so um he totally rebelled against it he
says oh this is all a lie then and he I
think he went a little bit crazy
uh but he got involved in basically the
trying to find out the truth
and uh he
he said that everything he had been told
as a kid was a lie that
people cheated on their [ __ ] spouses
that uh they were gays and lesbians
going on and hiding it uh that um people
were having sex with children that uh
they were just he just said the place
was just
kind of filthy so he just Dove right
into it he he said [ __ ] it then I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it too and
I'm gonna do worse you know and that's
that's where the [ __ ] just decide
[ __ ] got off on it wrote about it and
he eventually getting around he got
locked up and all those writings you
know basically porn is what he was
writing
he's writing it in prison and he was
[ __ ] handing it out selling it he had
people with friends of his [ __ ] take
his manuscripts and [ __ ] have them
printed and he was making a lot of money
in prison in the Bastille writing
[ __ ] kinky BDSM porn and this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] much harder than you would
imagine much harder involving all kinds
of Cruelty you know forcing women to
have sex with dudes who had syphilis and
then sewing them closed so they would
get it 100 and just all kinds of weird
[ __ ] I mean that's what I'm saying it's
like the thing about it is that if you
because I know some people like are into
kind of like extreme horror like stuff
like that like I'm not super into it but
I read it sometimes but pretty much
anything that people come up with
nowadays it's like super shocking I'm
like Marquita said probably already
wrote about it yeah a long time ago
decided wrote about that in the 1700s
like I said nothing new Under the Sun
taking virgin girls and beating them up
and [ __ ] putting stinging nettle on
them and making them do just being
depraved and you know he was all into
the dam
submission and bondage and being
dominant and dominant submissive stuff
and did he ever let anybody peg him yeah
I think he did he did because he had a
that seems like something that he would
want to experience yeah he had like a
gay
manservant who was his boyfriend and
they'd go out and pick up women and
do stuff and he'd be doing stuff to some
and they were mostly hookers that he was
dealing with he'd be doing stuff to him
while his uh serving to be
not paganives [ __ ] him basically you
know so yeah he was he was he was
[ __ ] trisexual he'd try it
well yeah I mean that seemed to be like
his life's work that he was just gonna
be the giver and the receipt yeah like
of pretty much everything that he could
think of and you would think that you
know when you when you say the Marquee
and he had a man serve it and all this
kind of [ __ ] you were thinking of a dude
in his 40s or 50s no he was a teenager
when he was doing this
he was a teenager you know late teens
early 20s is when he started all this so
he was a kid by our standards
doing this he lived he lived into old
age but
he he lost all his money you know
[ __ ] wants to
once the once the monarchy got
overthrown and you know during the time
of you know Napoleon and everything his
money dried up because
aristocrats
and no nobility basically lived on
welfare the king gave him money every
month so they were kind of like welfare
or being nice yeah they just got money
for being a marquee you know with some
King somewhere would give me like a
[ __ ] up that's what they did so I
could live in the way to which I had
become accustomed
in a monarchy the poor people aren't on
welfare the [ __ ] royal people are on
welfare they don't make any money I mean
they don't do anything they don't have
jobs they just get free money
yeah they just lay around and be
decadent lay around be decadent
eating bon bons and whipping their
servants and whatnot
American Military 100 said have you
considered doing a main episode on video
nasties I think they did one but it was
a very long time ago that was like one
of our earliest shows
um I don't know it might behoove us to
do a revisit on that because that's
always kind of something I've been
really interested in
by the way if you haven't seen a horror
movie called sensor you might want to
see that I really really dug it I don't
you know I'm not I don't really like to
give recommendations across the board
because I know some people who like I
watched that because you said that it's
hooked and blah blah but I really really
like sensor and it's about that time
period like it's about a woman that
works at the bbfc you know what I mean
so um but I really like that and and the
weird thing about it too is that
I guess that I kind of feel like this is
happens with like um any kind of you
know bbfc or the mpa like in the US
which is kind of the same thing
um they it's just very arbitrary like
the standards that they apply you know
what I mean
and uh that was one of the interesting
things because some of the some of the
movies that turned up like on the video
nasties list for example in the UK
um you see those now and just like why
the [ __ ] was that on there I think a lot
of times they didn't even really watch
them or like they just thought the title
sounded like it should be banned or they
didn't like really watch it because
there's nothing in it you know what I
mean or nothing like by today's
standards that would be like nothing I
mean if you've seen some [ __ ]
you see the [ __ ] that flies nowadays and
nobody bats an eye but like back then
uh seanwell said Schindler's List had
dancers and tail coats and thigh highs
with top hats and Canes gotta say it
worked yeah I like that um that Cabaret
style of look and honestly like in the
ER I kind of feel like it was the early
to mid 2000s which is about the
mid-2000s there was
um a kind of a short-lived
goth subculture goth The Cabaret yeah so
uh Dresden dolls were probably like the
mate and I actually really like the
Dresden dolls yeah
um they were probably like the main
component but there were like some other
ones as well like I have a couple of CDs
that were like uh you know uh
compilations of like different bands
rasputina touched on some of that I
think yeah they were more medieval
though no rasputina was more 1800 or
1800s yeah 1900s like [ __ ] uh old
west kind of looking
but I think they did but some of the
sounds that they did kind of sounded
Cabaret I don't think they did it did
the dress
then it was uh who else did Cabaret type
[ __ ] I'm trying to think it was um [ __ ]
man Jill Tracy was another big one I
like her as well she kind of did that
role like kind of Cabaret style like
um Kurt vile type of sound Dresden dolls
was real good if you guys
they were good yeah
and they looked very much like that they
had like little derby hats and fish nets
and it was a guy and a girl like the guy
was a drummer and she was uh she played
piano and sang and he sang too yeah but
um yeah I was like their uh lyrics and
[ __ ] like that were really good too but
like yeah they had that you know the
little garters and all that kind of look
to it they kind of went a different
direction I don't think they're together
anymore because I think Amanda Palmer um
Amanda Palmer is like she did some solo
[ __ ] which was actually good she married
uh Neil Gaiman matter of fact
uh they had a kid and everything
uh let's see DJ Maniac said check your
DMs I watched a fun one last night okay
I will later
uh Richard Brown said sensor was
fantastic well I'm glad I'm not the only
one I loved that movie I just thought
that was one of my favorite horror films
that I've seen like in the past 10 years
easily there was just something about it
that like really
I don't know just the whole look of it
the whole vibe of it I was really into
it
um they're talking about sometime in
November like around Thanksgiving we
should review the movie Blood rage
sounds familiar it's a Thanksgiving
themed slasher I've heard of that I
might have seen it but I don't really
remember I think last year because one
of you guys sent us uh thanks killing
the thanks killing movies yeah like
about the killers
I'd say they kind of got worse as they
went but
that third one was kind of uh surreal
yeah
I had I had to see that [ __ ] again there
was we have them like that we have a
they were [ __ ] bizarre I'll put I
will give them that like I said I'm you
know I'm oh I meant to tell you I forgot
to tell you
there is a Kickstarter for making guess
what velocipaster two okay yeah and it's
already got like a [ __ ] ton of money
does it so apparently like oh it's a
masterpiece apparently we're not the
only ones that love that
I saw I didn't even realize but I saw I
was watching a video the other day and
here's what video was I watching I don't
even remember but somebody that I was
watching maybe it was Voltaire or maybe
because I don't remember who it was but
they mentioned they're like oh hey no it
wasn't it was like this girl that I
watched like this nerdy girl that like
reviews movies sometimes and she's like
oh hey they're doing a velociraptor too
like they have a Kickstarter please go
and give them money I need to see that
again so yeah so I'm like really excited
about yeah they need to make that I mean
I hope they don't [ __ ] it up because the
first one was just so good
well what made that so good was the
writing so they got the same writer
they'll be all right I love the last
Master well like I said that was like
the one
one of the few instances where they
seemingly set out to make a bad movie
but it's still kind of like because I
kind of feel like and I've talked about
this before but it's like it's really
really hard to make an intentionally bad
movie like on purpose it's still like
entertaining because it's it always just
comes across as like to try hard but
like look at this stupid movie that
we're making but this one didn't because
it came across as like really genuine
but also they were aware that they were
making a bad movie but they were not but
they were still like all in and they
were like it wasn't a bad movie yeah but
that's what I mean it kind of came
around again so they got like they got
it exactly right and that's like a
really really hard it was a low budget
movie right it was a little budget movie
but it was a great movie but they leaned
into the low budget you're right and
they were just like it was it wasn't a
bad movie it was a good movie it was
a low budget movie done right on
steroids knowing that it's low budget
and it was all just done with writing
and [ __ ] the way it was just
everything see velocity you'll like it I
think it's free on TV matter of fact or
it used to be
I mean it was for a while I don't know I
don't know about nowadays
it's just it's so lovable yeah it's like
yeah
I don't understand you could like not
love that movie it's just it's so
lovable I don't know what else to say
especially if you're our generation
yeah it's just there's something like I
said it was it was so Earnest yeah I
think that's what I liked about it it's
like they didn't try to be like oh wink
wink or ironic or oh we're making a bad
movie isn't that funny they didn't try
to be like that they were just like came
across as very Earnest that I really
liked it another one that I liked it was
kind of like that a little bit was turbo
kid which is a French movie
remember turbo kid yeah I like turbo kid
a lot what's that French or Australia I
thought it was an Australian I thought
it was Australian I think it was a it
was a it was a French movie that was all
I think American cast or Australian cast
when I thought it was French movie
though it might have been but yeah I
remember most of the Castro's Australia
yeah that also might be freon to be yeah
or you or it was for a while yeah a lot
of people have talked about like that
that's one that gets brought up a lot
when people talk about like underrated
movies I don't have it man I need that
one on Blu-ray yeah I liked that a lot
yeah Richard Brown said saint Maude I
really like St mod I did a review of
Saint Mod like by myself but that was
like Vincent wow Australian well some
yeah that's what I thought I didn't
think that it was the French yeah I was
pretty sure wasn't it a French director
or a French writer that's what I
remember I thought it was Australia okay
but yeah I was pretty sure it was
Australian maybe you're thinking of
another movie okay Danny Rowling said
terrifyer too hyped up uh you'll need a
vomit bag promotion yeah which wasn't
needed but still a great Sequel and
violent as [ __ ] and I wouldn't be
surprised if other horror movies copy
them with the gore I do want to see that
like I'm not
I don't mind some gore like I said
usually like I I like all kind of
different horror I'll just I'll watch
anything if somebody says it's good and
I like gory [ __ ] depends on my mood
usually I like psychological ghost story
kind of [ __ ] but I really really did
like the first terrifier I just had like
a really really good time with it and so
I kind of want to see this second one
too because everybody said like it's the
bloodiest [ __ ] most violent thing
ever so we'll see we'll see
I mean
it'll take a lot to impress me is what
I'm saying
um somebody said uh wait where did I see
it oh it's gone now oh Mike said uh Gore
films do nothing for me yeah I mean
I said it depends sometimes I like that
um I don't just like Gore for the sake
of it but I don't mind like or if it's
like in there and there's like some
other [ __ ] going on
Danny Rowling said Jenny you said last
year you would review bloodrage this
year since you didn't do it last year
also free on YouTube okay well I'm gonna
write that down because otherwise I'll
forget checking you on it
yeah he checked you see well la because
last year we did thanks killing yeah
that's why
blood rage might be on shutter or it was
for a while because I remember seeing it
when I scrolled through there but it
might not be on there now because stuff
comes and goes
um Mackie Mac vrchat LOL I jump in the
right time when they said molded [ __ ]
molded peen
yeah we were talking about all the armor
or whatever
art the clown is the [ __ ] and I don't
find clowns scary at all I think the
best thing about art the Clown
is that he doesn't talk
like he's kind of like a mime actually
more than a clown
you know yeah
but
I don't know it's just I I found the
first one like really really
entertaining
so
I'm sure the second one like I know that
the second one is just like getting all
the hype because they're like oh my God
it's like the [ __ ] goriest movie like
ever moved I don't know people are
saying it's a glorious movie ever made
but I'm like probably Dead Alive with
like a word but
I've heard that it's like super gory I'm
getting in the mood to go out tonight
are you yeah all right we'll go we're
gonna shut it down in a bit because you
want something to eat before we go
yeah I mean it's only 7 24 though yeah
we have to start getting ready and
everything we leave here I don't wanna I
don't want to be like last time where
I'm showing up at like 10 30 and can't
find any parking yeah but that was
Halloween I don't care I don't know what
it is no I'm just saying that that's why
we couldn't find I want to get there at
around nine something to ten o'clock 10
o'clock
yeah uh American Military 100 said the
Spanish horror comedy the day the Beast
is a good one too um I reviewed that one
Last Christmas I want to say yeah I
really liked that a lot too I really
like that a lot too but I'm pretty sure
I think it was last Christmas I reviewed
that or somewhere around there just go
and look for my on my flickers of fear
series I'm pretty sure that I reviewed
that
uh Dana Rowling said terrifier one and
two are funny in a dark way yeah I kind
of feel like movies that are like super
super gory like that
um they just they go around because
they're not even like gross they just go
around and become funny again now I'm
not talking about stuff that's like
[ __ ] disturbing you know what I mean
like new French extremity or something
like that which are gory but are also
like really disturbing and [ __ ] up
like the situations but something like
terrifier
that's just meant to be like over the
top and like funny I thought that was
supposed to be funny do you know what I
mean I found it funny
you know it should I don't know it
depends on the cost on the concept on
the context you know what I'm saying DJ
Maniac said the movie I watched last
night is the same company that did the
distribution for velocity Pastor oh okay
yeah he sent me a message earlier but I
don't know what the movie is
yeah I can't what
what yeah
she's been like making a little face
back there she's making a little face oh
baby she's like you guys are boring me
yeah oh Pokey and bored huh okay she's
like you guys
let's see what's funny is that she'll
leave us alone all day
well she's sleeping she's sleeping she's
sleeping most of the day yeah well she's
either sleeping or she's like jumping on
my desk licking my keyboard so I can't
get anything done yeah she does that too
well and I was
I've got to be funny if I like maybe
like printed out a little sign on there
that said Pookie parking because she
jumps up on my desk I have to move my
keyboard like off to the side because
others she jumps up on my desk and then
like she just like lays out
like on my desk so I can't really like
put the keyboard where I would normally
put it to type because she just like
lays there and it's like what I'm just
gonna lay here sorry
philosopher had a company doing his
distribution yeah I mean you know
Danny Rowling said what are Thomas
Jennings thoughts on that new David
Harbor a Christmas film coming out that
looks like Silent Night deadly night I
haven't seen the trailer for that but
now I'm intrigued I like Christmas
horror movies and I like uh David Harbor
as well so you know
Hugo said I don't like terrifier
probably because I don't find clowns
scary I don't either to be honest with
you
um but I just liked it because I thought
I didn't think he was scary I just I
thought the gore was funny you know what
I mean you guys don't scare me at all
none of them do I mean yeah normally
normally they're kind of gross but I
don't know he's good yeah normally I
don't get scared by them like so in a
way like it's always kind of like epic
when that does happen like when
something does scare me or give me a
nightmare or something like that I'm
like woo you did your job because it
takes a lot like to do that but that's
not necessarily like always why I watch
them you know what I mean like if
something's just gory that's not gonna
scare me and clowns don't scare me
so I don't
I was saying this before because I kind
of feel like there was especially after
uh you know it chapter one came out like
with Pennywise and everything but I feel
like it was kind of a trend even before
that
because of all those urban legends like
about all those people dressing up like
clowns and standing around being creepy
or whatever and I kind of feel like
there was kind of a moment where longer
than a moment where everyone was like
ooh scary clowns and everything like
that isn't there a word for it like
colrophobia or whatever it is and I was
just kind of like
I get why some people think clowns are
scary you know what I mean I get that
because it's like yeah it's a person but
they have makeup on you can't really and
they look like they're smiling it's like
yeah I get that but I don't know to me
they're just not that scary so I kind of
feel like any
any movie that's gonna have that as your
villain because I feel like there was a
million there's not as many as was the
shark movies that's for sure did
somebody do clown shark
they must have they've done shark
everything else I kind of feel like they
should have combined clown and shark
but I don't know any movie that is has
like a clown as your antagonist is
usually not good but I did like
terrifier oh the one movie that we did
like that was just called clown do you
remember that movie yeah it was a good
movie yeah you remember yeah I really
liked that movie it's just called clown
I think it came out
2014 15 16 somewhere around there
where he puts the clown outfit on like
to entertain at his son's birthday party
or whatever and then he can't get it off
because it's not actually a clown
costume it's like the skin of like a
clown demon
um and you clown with a W yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and like it's a
Nordic multiple children get eaten yeah
it's pretty epic I mean it's like I
really really liked that movie clowns
the the the outfit started to stick to
him and then it grew into him and it
started to modify him it took over kind
of like the damn
the Venom thing for [ __ ] Spider-Man
it's like that yeah like it's at first
like he can't get that you couldn't get
it off the nose off and he couldn't get
the hair off and he's like trying to
pull it off and he turned into what
looked like an evil [ __ ] clown and it
was like body horror he was eating
children and [ __ ] yeah yeah it was
pretty awesome and like they'll go over
and like then the big like those big
climax that happened like in a Chuck E
cheese or a Chuck E cheese ish
restaurant
but I don't know yeah there was
something about that one I really liked
because he's well made it was well
written yeah and like the characters
like the guy was sympathetic because he
wasn't an evil he was just like a
schlubby dad see he was just trying to
do something nice for his kids and then
he like he ended up like in this
horrible situation here's the thing this
what makes or breaks a movies not
special effects or all this or the
[ __ ] stars or the budget nope all the
[ __ ] mistakes that the Hollywood
[ __ ] system Studio system makes
that's not what makes or breaks a movie
it's the writing
it's the writing and football I mean
that's your foundation yeah and if the
writing and your character yeah well
that's all part of the writing [ __ ]
if that is not done right you'll never
have a movie
you can have a
philosophaster was made with nothing the
writing was [ __ ] great that's why
that movie stood out
the writing was perfect for what it was
they were working with
and I kind of feel like I was like that
too yeah it was really good because
normally I wouldn't I wouldn't like even
watch a movie because there's so many
that's like ooh evil clown I mean
there's go on to be seriously and put
clown in the search bar you'll be amazed
at how many [ __ ] horror movies come
up with that [ __ ] so it's like not
normally something I would watch but we
just ended up watching it I think it was
actually on Netflix for a little while I
think we might have seen it on there but
it's like yeah that the writing was good
the characters were good the guy was
sympathetic it was like a good story
behind it and that all goes to [ __ ]
writing yeah right
if you don't have a good Rider you don't
have anything I mean well that's kind of
your foundation right yeah the script
you can have I mean [ __ ] man I've seen
movies that cost like 200 million
dollars to make and have like big actors
in them and stuff like that that were
fine but I didn't remember them like
afterward because it just didn't
resonate with me and you don't even need
a great director as long as the Director
sticks to a great script [ __ ] and he
shoots the script [ __ ] the story
comes across then you you the strip is
great you gotta you got a great movie
yeah you know but having a good having a
good [ __ ] director helps oh yeah it
helps because they can steer the ship in
a certain direction and they can give it
a certain like aesthetic and a certain
look and a certain like you know style
and then the edit is [ __ ] critical
too I also feel like editing is very
underrated to you same thing with
[ __ ] sound you got to have fun with
that too especially in horror yeah the
score yeah
account will sound design and score is
like a huge component I mean it is in
all movies but I kind of feel like in
horror especially
um sound is like really really really
important then philosophaster had a
shitty score but it [ __ ] was great it
was epic because it fit the movie they
knew what they were doing
they knew what they were doing yeah
everything about that like even though
the movie looked like it was made for
like about five dollars yep um
but you got the sense that everybody
that worked on it they knew what they
were doing one they knew yeah they knew
what they were doing and two this was
like a labor of love like a project that
they were all like really passionate
about
and I think that really came across like
I said that genuineness that earnestness
it really did come across they weren't
just like making some dumb knockoff it's
like hey let's make a stupid movie you
know what I mean which I kind of feel
like that happens a lot especially
nowadays because it's so much easier to
get your movie to a wider audience which
like I said I think that's a good thing
but you're gonna get a lot of like
shitty product in that thing too and
it's like that's why I like and I hate
to like keep picking on the people that
made Ouija shark but that's kind of like
the difference between because we watch
those like right around the same time
that's the big difference between
philosophaster and Ouija shark to me it
seemed like velocipaster they were just
kind of like one they came up with a
great it's a great concept they were
really good at like marketing it like
the Poster's great like everything about
is great it's just like a great script
it was a great idea and they understood
the audience and the culture of the
audience because there's all these
cultural references if you grew up in
our generation to video games and
[ __ ] ninjas and [ __ ] karate and
[ __ ] dinosaurs and just
crazy [ __ ] but they they understood the
audience it seemed a lot more informed a
lot more culturally informed whereas
like something like Ouija shark well not
a terrible film but you could tell that
they were just like hey Ouija boards are
big and sharks are big let's combine
that won't that be hilarious and that
was probably as far as they thought
about it it wasn't hilarious I kind of
it wasn't really and they had cute girls
in there they knew that would be a draw
but there wasn't a script there to make
you care about anything there was not
enough story there to make to make that
work
yeah that was the difference I mean that
that concept you could do something well
I believe you can do something with
pretty much any concept if you know what
you're doing no matter how dumb it
sounds
um in the right hands the [ __ ] could
work yeah but if all you have is like
kind of a slightly funny sounding
concept like oh let's make like a ghost
shark that is drawn by a Ouija board
like yeah that's kind of funny uh you
could do something with that but I kind
of feel like that's as far as it went
they're like hey that's a funny concept
and then they're like now just do it
like they didn't really think of it like
anywhere past that point so it didn't
really like work right it wasn't as
funny as it should have been I mean that
[ __ ] should have been hilarious right
not good but it wasn't that goes back to
[ __ ] turbo kid
turbo kid
was very culturally informed
the writing was really good but the
budget was a lot higher than the other
two and you can see it it's still an
enjoyable movie it's a superhero movie
happening in a post-apocalyptic world so
there's all kinds of [ __ ] references
there's all kinds of tie-ins with say
like Mad Max
[ __ ] Fallout The Fallout video game
series
um
what is it [ __ ] adventures in the
forbidden zone or Metal Storm adventures
in the forbidden zone or things no it's
Metal Storm that's what it was
evening because you had [ __ ] oh
what's his name in it what was that
Ironside Michael Ironside said it
it's just it's good in there yeah it's
just there's a lot of good there's a lot
of good cultural references in in in uh
turbo kid
and it was an upbeat
action adventure movie yeah it was like
almost like a throwback 80s yeah
throwback almost kind of like Cherry
2000. it did remind me of that exactly
yeah yeah and it was I kind of think it
was better than Cherry because when we
watched we've rewatched Cherry 2000 yeah
like probably a year or two ago and I
didn't like it as much as I did back
then yeah it was it was better than
Cherry 2000. remember Cherry 2000 was
not working from a culturally informed
space either because that's true it had
not yet become retro right so it
couldn't refer to itself
yeah
if you were to remake Cherry 2000 you
could do a lot better now yeah why
hasn't anybody done that yeah I would
have remade that is somebody working on
that right now there's a lot of good
[ __ ] in there in Cherry 2000 that could
you could remake that a bit because I
like the original Cherry 2000 but it's
not it's a little bit I mean it's kind
of like drags in places a little bit
boring like in some places you could
take that concept and like do something
with that though and it's a love story
happening in a [ __ ] futuristic
post-apocalyptic dystopian where guy
[ __ ] his sex bot broken he's in a
place where you gotta have a contract to
date a girl
and so he hires uh this mercenary chick
to go out and go into these forbidden
[ __ ] apocalyptic zones to find the
[ __ ] Warehouse where they can get
that ship to fix to fix his set because
it's an old one it's an old one yeah
that's so like I said that's a great
concept that's a great guy and what was
and uh it was what was that actress's
name that played the uh oh [ __ ] man
uh the name the name of his [ __ ]
robot it was a model Cherry 2000 that's
what it's called there's a little Yuppie
chick my brother's punk band was called
Cherry 2000 for a time back in the day
back in the 90s
the uh the actress that [ __ ] played
basically she's kind of like a female
Han Solo she decides was that it wasn't
Melanie Griffin oh okay there's a red
how do I pull that out of my eyes it was
a red-headed
[ __ ] post-apocalyptic Melanie
Griffith with the [ __ ]
with with a with a 64 Mustang souped up
with dirt tires on it and a [ __ ]
folding stock [ __ ] mini 14 full auto
mini 14 was it ACR 556 I think it's
about the name of it which I had one
light a lot like that it wasn't
stainless though she had that and it was
suppressed she had [ __ ] a dragon
[ __ ] missile in there there's all
kinds of [ __ ] she had she gotta fight
her way into this damn
post-apocalyptic forbidden zone to go
get this [ __ ] robot part and there's
[ __ ] car for a sex spot but he loved
her though yeah he loved that bot and
they didn't make that model anymore and
he and she was special to him he's going
along with Melanie Griffith and he's
[ __ ] to try to [ __ ] his to revive
his dream girl but it turns out [ __ ]
Melanie Griffith's the dream girl all
along sure you know he didn't see it
though you know it's just it's just
funny you know which was a very common
theme in like movies back then yeah like
guy hooks up with like some girl who
initially seems kind of like rough and
blah blah yeah like looking for this
other chick like I'm gonna hire this one
chick to help me look for this like hot
chick that I really like but he's like
oh I guess I like this girl yeah I think
I think that is eventually resolved
because they leave Cherry behind yeah
because she overweighed the plot the
airplane
airplane
Richard Brown says new Cherry 2000 with
Dakota Johnson now are they really
making that or is that just your or is
that just your dream yeah
because actually she would probably be a
good Cherry 2000 I kind of feel like I
kind of feel now Melanie Griffith was
great in that movie
she was real good at it yeah she played
um she looked cute she looked rough
but she still kind of had a [ __ ] kind
of a punk rock look to her you know she
was still attractive and she had a
little bit of a punk rock attitude yeah
which is kind of a tomboy I always kind
of like that running around she was kind
of like uh it's kind of like boy and his
dog
Don Johnson yeah that's a very similar
version of boy and his dog yeah they're
real close
Pacific Heights Danny rolling brought
that up we should probably review that
movie too because I really like that
movie
and I had kids like people keep bringing
it up and I'm just like oh yeah we need
to re-watch that because I really like
that because that's a really I loved all
those [ __ ] throw I I've been wanting
to do single white female for a long
time but I put it in the poll a couple
times but it never wins you know what I
mean which is kind of a bummer because
[ __ ] man not not often you get to see a
dude killed with a high-heeled shoe you
know what I'm saying I'm into it
uh Danny Rowling said Michael Ironside
is doing Hallmark movies now is he
really no [ __ ] like wait Michael Irish
side I mean it's work I can't like [ __ ]
I mean how okay how many movies
do Hallmark make probably a [ __ ] ton of
them because it seems like there's
always a new one yeah especially around
Christmas they make like a ton of
Christmas movies I can maybe I don't
know if they make ones for other
holidays too but it's just it seems like
whenever I watch something on like um
you know to be or Hulu or something that
has like commercials like a lot of times
you'll see commercials for the you know
the Hallmark Christmas movies and the
lifetime Christmas movies I don't know
if they made Chris I don't know if they
make movies about other holidays but
um
let's see uh y'all should review copycat
too yeah I've been wanting to do that
one too because I think I put that one
in the poll at least once maybe twice
and that didn't win either but that's it
I actually saw that in the theater that
had Sigourney Weaver in it Sigourney
Weaver and uh Holly Hunter wasn't Holly
Hunter in that
yeah it was like a serial killer movie
that was also good
also good
and let's see uh Danny Rowling said I
guess he's talking about Pacific Heights
still I just got that on DVD and Beverly
D'Angelo shows her boobs in that film
Pacific Heights oh yeah that's right she
was in [ __ ] European Vacation wasn't
she she's the wife in European
you remember the wife in European
Vacation yeah that's right I remember
that's yeah she was in about all the
movies she was in a bunch of stuff too
but I mean that's what I mostly remember
she was in all the vacation movies right
yeah
where she only had some wait was she in
the first time she was in the first one
and the second one yeah I think and he
took my blood yeah
I think she was in just the one that was
just called vacation and then the one
that was European Vacation yeah I
remember European Vacation the most
because that was like on [ __ ] HBO or
Cinemax like all the time and I probably
saw it like 200 times like in the 80s
Richard Brown Hallmarks a scanner at
Christmas with my clients
not gonna lie he's gonna be sitting
around the Christmas tree like blowing
people's heads up
somebody make that movie
[Laughter]
jeffreyard said it's so obvious that
Hallmark movies are producing Canada I
recognize 80 of the actors from Stargate
issue one of the outer limits yeah I
kind of feel like a lot of uh movies
particularly ones that are supposed to
be set in New York they usually film
them in Toronto do they not because it's
like cheaper I mean it's cheaper to get
like the it's almost impossible to film
in New York nowadays because it's like
too expensive and it's like well they
don't want you like you know
getting in the way of all the [ __ ] so
uh Danny Rowling said there's a thriller
four pack DVD that comes with Pacific
Heights copycat the crush and diabolique
the 90s version
you know I actually might have to invest
in that because those are all good
movies I haven't seen I just recently
did a review on the original diabolique
uh from the 60s 60s right yeah
um
but I I'd be interested to like re-watch
I think I saw the 90s one but I don't
really remember that much about it
because that was Sharon Stone right and
wasn't
um was Isabella Johnny in that I want to
say I'm trying to remember the poster
it's been a while since I've seen that
and the crush that was what's her face
that was in Batman and Robin right
Alicia Silverstone wasn't she in the
Crush
always
Hallmark I always use the same exact
gazebo
the only reason I know like I said the
only reason that I know like some of
these movies
um especially like the more recent ones
is because of uh Nick doramia's channel
because he really likes to review like
lately he's been doing like a lot of um
well he did like some shitty to be
horror movies like for Halloween which
were like really funny but he also does
like a lot of like shitty Christian
movies but when he's not doing that he
really likes either weird Disney films
from the 90s or lifetime or Hallmark
movies that are like super cheesy and so
I always liked what to watch those like
he just like picks them apart and
they're so funny
uh do you like Darren Aronofsky yes I do
very much
um Tom actually really really likes Noah
he hasn't seen a lot of Darren
aronofsky's other movies
um like he's never seen a Requiem for a
Dream and he didn't see mother and he
didn't see pie
um but I've seen all of those and I
really liked all of them yeah yeah
you would probably like Requiem for a
Dream even though it's depressing as
[ __ ]
sounds familiar not sure about pie I
really liked pie but a lot I mean that
one's kind of like that was one of his
earlier films so it's like really
surreal not sure if you'd like mother or
not I'd really dug it but who's the
director Darren Aronofsky a guy that
didn't know it yeah yeah I like Noah a
lot yeah
you might like mother as well I did a
review of it not too long ago and I was
trying to decide I couldn't decide if
you would have liked it or not it's also
kind of like a Biblical allegory but
it's like batshit insane
you know yeah so you might dig it I'm
not really sure
yeah Alicia Silverstone and Carrie oh I
forgot Carrie always was in that okay I
remembered Alicia Silverstone was in it
but I didn't remember that Carrie always
was in it
uh oh and the wrestler oh
that's I forgot about that one you would
probably really like that one
Mickey O'Rourke is in that I saw that in
the theater that's like really really
good yeah he's made like some kick-ass
movies I don't think about it I think
he'd really like the wrestler it's like
that's also kind of sad but it's also
like a really good movie
all right well you look like you're yeah
it's about time Helen Black Swan yeah I
still haven't done Black Swan we have
that we own that I do I bought it yeah
that was aronowsky yeah okay we have it
I might do that at some point too
because I really like that movie yeah
but um all right so you want to go out
tonight so I have to cook for you're
kind of getting you have to cook for it
and see then I gotta change and you you
have to well yeah I gotta change I guess
I don't have time to like redo makeup
but I can redo outfit I guess all right
I can just put more makeup on on top of
what I already got I didn't put this
makeup I only put this makeup on like a
couple hours before the show so okay
it's not that it's it's not that grotty
you know what I mean
all right so uh hopefully you guys have
a good evening this Friday evening and
hopefully you guys have a good day
tomorrow because tomorrow we're taking
the day off Sunday we'll be back on 6
p.m uh Eastern Standard time we're going
to be talking about this movie right
here
tombstone
because we watched that last night so
we're going to be reviewing that on
Sunday so because Louie sent us that so
come back on Sunday we will see you guys
then have a good safe weekend you guys
and we'll see you on Sunday bye